my name is Karolina Aisha I am a
mathematician working at the Institute
for pure and applied mathematics in Rio
de Janeiro Brazil so I work mostly with
the mathematical research and I also
teach graduate classes here I think
so there is a sort of collective of
women in mathematics in Brazil that
evolved organically over the last few
years and culminated with the
organization of the world meeting for
women in mathematics in 2018 so in
preparation for that we organized a
series of roundtables about women in
mathematics throughout the country and
this had a global coordination but local
organizers in each University and that
was very empowering not only strengthen
the the local groups of women in
mathematics but also connected them into
a bigger Network and now we are
preparing for 2019 the first Brazilian
meeting for women in mathematics will
happen in July
so whenever I am involved in some
projects working with other people with
other with groups of people I tried to
work as horizontal as possible
and listening to try to make the
decision move collective as opposed to
too hierarchical and this is because I
really believe that when there is a
group working together a new
intelligence emerges and it's a group
intelligence that is only possible if
one works horizontally